now when it comes out you're saying you
say yeah my dad Ali okay how could and
help you Allah says in the Quran clearly
if you was to ask you to the heavens and
the Earth
they affirmed the quresh do you know the
quresh believes in Allah do you know
this so how come they confidence
Islam that is establishing a Masjid and
a community center if you don't need to
build this mystery Allah build the house
for you in Jannah with bricks of gold
and silver every person who prays in
this Masjid every child that memorized
the Quran you will inshallah share in
that reward donate now guys and do not
delay
[Music]
no
yeah so what happened is there was this
right there was an individual I don't
know if there's a loser I can't remember
yeah one of them were a righteous person
who used to serve the pilgrims and give
them food so when this person died what
happened is they buried them yeah I
don't know if it was a male or female
they buried them and then slowly slowly
they turned it into a shrine and as time
went by bro what they did is they
started to give certain attributes of
Allah to that person now that person
never claimed they are God that person
never claims they have the attributes of
Allah but what happened is they started
worshiping that person that's the reason
why as time went by they started to take
it as an idol as a God so what they
would say if you go to the quresh Allah
says in the Quran clearly if you was to
ask them you created the heavens and the
Earth they'll say Allah
do you know this
good so the quresh they accepted they
said Allah yes we believe Allah exists
we just use the idols to get closer to
him between him
physically meaningful they've got the
they've got the same like things as what
Allah can do and then there's a
metaphorical
I don't I don't go for example I won't
go and say I'll leave I need a lot or
for example I would I would have to say
mother because I'll go through okay my
Imam that the people that the prophet
said you should follow after I passed
you should follow my twelve percentage
follow follow not not worship yeah of
course now now worship listen to what
I'm saying yeah let's I'm sticking I'm
sticking to the qureshia so the quresh
what they did is worship let me tell you
how now the qurai what they did is they
started to idolize these statues these
statues were righteous individuals going
back to the point of the quresh because
this is our topic at hand now the
Christians
started worshiping Jesus instantly no
okay so what did they do is they first
say they first said he is the son of God
then eventually in the Council of
Nigerian 325 they came together made the
decision that Jesus is a positive God
now why did they come to that conclusion
the problem is this actually any time we
get someone and bring them to a level
like look at for example Jesus the Jews
they slander him they belittle him they
degrade him the Christians take him to a
level of worship Muslims are in the
middle we say no Jesus was the prophet
of God his mother was honorable woman
we say to the Christians don't worship
them and we say to the Jews stop
slandering them but we believe that
anyone for that matter now when it comes
to Ali you're saying you say
okay how could Allah
um
let's suppose I'm here unless I'm here
with a gun I've got a gun to your head
how's that is going to help you
listen I don't know how is it going to
help you you know what you know what
that's what I'm saying he won't stop if
it's written then you're supposed to
treat me you I'll be sure best way
that's correct but Ali helping you is
not in that like that when you say I'm
that Ali or even say Muhammad or anyone
for that matter
because what you're doing now is you're
giving Allah is the one that helps you
are giving an attribute to Allah
to a creation that is dead do you
believe them is dead
but what we say is that he cannot Aid
you so we're saying let's not fall into
what the Christians fell into to our
brothers the same goes to the sunnis
anyone for that matter let's not
associate partner because you said yeah
but he's close to Allah so actually so
what if they close there is the closest
why
okay so what does the Quran say
s they are physically dead but their
souls are alive like Allah
well there's different something they
become Greek words they engender there's
many things
basically they're dead but actually
their soul is living and they're with
the Lord
we accept that we don't have a problem
no I'm saying for example that the
Shahid do not look do not say that they
are dead rather they are alive with
their lord I can't touch them no you
can't but in their grave you can if they
are there you said like right now yeah
yes that's spiritually you say no no no
no no no not here
in the Quran and we are giving them
sustenance with the Lord so do not say
they are dead rather they are alive but
how not in the physical sense we say for
example that they're alive that's why we
say the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him when we give Sam the angels
was killed
look this is the areas where I am not
version I don't know but what I know is
an absolute you know what it is it's an
insult alley to say that was there his
daughter and he was just chilling there
do you know what kind of a man Ali was
you are a share bro
I know I know it's after Prophet do you
know what color man that is after after
he how does it mean
s
he was the lady hmm according to you
lady in what as in as in who's to follow
between eyeshadows
no no no no problem
to us actually the difference is this
both of them are belong to us look we
love Musa we love Jesus peace people but
the Christians they hate Muhammad peace
with him the Jews hate Muhammad peace be
upon him so with us it's like this we
love them both we don't differentiate
you guys differentiate but now you're
going to be off topic okay let's come
back to topic the alley that I know no
way in hell is he gonna watch his
daughter be killed and he's going to
watch it it's not the other than I know
he's the soldier of Allah and I bro let
me tell you something one of the reasons
one of the reasons when I came to Islam
one of the reasons I have time to fight
because okay I know one of the reasons
one of the reasons exactly okay listen
to me you said he's such a soul I said
Ali was a brave man he used to go into
the battlefield kill Helaman thank you
you agreed yes well that's one of the
reasons why when I came to Islam the
reason I call myself Ali is because I
will look at his characters and traits
bro one of the reasons one of the
reasons why I chose that name for myself
is because I'm a soldier but I want I
want to be like him so for you to come
and tell me he's watching his daughter
get killed and watching it's a big
insult to Alley huh
he was known as a Sadiq when the person
look you see when he asks I don't like
you know why no because you feel as if
look I love this
man I love them equally that's all I'm
gonna say I don't like this question
because you're making me feel as if I
don't like Ali as much I love now come
to the issue of shirk do you believe
your imams have power of the Unseen
I don't know
thank you but I'm saying you're saying
that he knew all the knowledge even the
prophet Muhammad didn't know some stuff
he was asked about
correct me if I'm wrong brothers and he
said the one he's asking there's no more
than the ones being asked so wait so why
follow someone that doesn't have
knowledge
you'll speak about Prophet Muhammad
no but because I don't deem him to be I
believe Allah is the all-knowing that's
my point
can Allah give the knowledge to the
prophet did Allah gave Holy Quran to
Prophet yes exactly okay did he give the
knowledge can he give knowledge
that if Quran has all the knowledge
everything
actually last week I had a brother come
here Rob he was he's a Sunni brother
he's a celebrity mother he was arguing
with me because I said I don't believe
what's your God it's not switching on me
because
I don't believe
so I said I believe the ones look like I
said you before I hear there's a certain
criteria anyone that falls into that
he's a Sunni if he's a Shia if he said
this if he said that they all they will
become a cafe do you agree that if I say
this person is all-knowing is he a cafe
or a Believer am I a capital disbelief
if I say who's the owner thank you so if
Ashia says that it's a cafe if the sun
he says that he's a cafe if he's a
grandma
their judgment
please
so no I'm not
it's not all knowing Allah is the
all-knowing yes Allah is all-powerful
that's what I'm saying do we agree
let's make let's make this something
that the viewers don't see us here
brother
I'm having a dialogue with you I want to
learn from you and I just want to hear
me I'll give you an advice yeah yes
please whenever you ask a question if
you're going to ask people who don't
know everything about she is a problem
no no I'm just I'm just telling people
yeah you're right you're right if they
pick on ignorant people genuine
questions
if you don't know anything about it
I am ignorant I am ignorant on this
matter I just want to talk about
something I can't learn from someone who
is not 100 100 that's why Imam comes in
as well
anybody that falls into this category is
committing and becomes a disability
so it's not Shia it's not this it's
anyone do you get it I really appreciate
it thank you very much anyway let me
just let me just do like brothers and
sisters like well I'll be honest I came
here walking the brothers that our sheer
Brothers wanted to take a picture we'll
just go into a discussion please don't
turn this into Shia suddenly well like
fear Allah we had the discussion we have
a disagreement but we can talk like
civilized people like I said to them
before to me anybody that gets an
attribute of Allah and applies it to
anyone if he's a Sunni if he's a Shia if
he's a Bradley if he's a Sufi if he's a
selfie I don't care what it is it is an
act of prefer and it's an act of if
they knowingly say this person is the
all-knowing that's all I said please in
the comment section don't insult each
other don't say it as soon as it is it
was just a nice discussion and leave it
as a life because at the end of the day
there's an adamant to talk in I don't
see them as my enemy okay simple as that
and that's what I'm going to leave
foreign
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah